hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from round 8 of
the 2018 of the box no boy championship
it's a game between Viswanathan Anand
and the Fabiano Caruana now regarding
the photo challenge from the previous
video yes of course it is a young Hikaru
Nakamura
so okay we've had a couple of other
challenges so far and they were since
all of you knew the answers really easy
it's time for for a really difficult one
in this photo challenge you are able to
win five points for each person you
recognized in the photo there are five
people in the photo so you should know
usually I believe you will know at least
three but maybe maybe some of you will
know even for and some of you who truly
have vast knowledge will know even five
so here it is enjoy the photo now let's
see it let's see how you do so don't you
don't have to do it in any particular
order you know you just have to
recognize all the people in the photo so
uh good luck to everyone and let's check
out this game so we do have only one
photo from this event
it's a photo from from the opening Fabi
if I'll be holding I believe that's a
pawn but anyways the the game is much
more interesting than the photo so let's
check it out and opens it with efore we
have E 5 Knight to f3 and of course by
now all of you should know what phablet
plays in this position of course Knight
to f6 he goes for the petrov defense a
nice captures on e5 and chooses the
classical variation d6 and Knight f3
Knight captures on e4 d3 kicking the
knight back Knight f6 and now d4 d5 and
the Bishop to d3 so the standard the
standard line and Bishop to d6 pretty
much transposed into the French defense
exchange variation now we have castles
castles and Bishop to g5 pinning the
knight h6 attacking the bishop bishop to
h4 and here I believe Bobby discovered a
new move c6 does exist in the database
Bishop to d6 also as an opening maneuver
but here in the knight to c6 is played
and i checked the database and it seems
like this is the only game played with
this move so far so okay c3 we have G
five brush up to g3
and now comes some 94 a very strong at
night in the center we have Bishop
captures and here is the very nice
moment in the game of course black can
play Knight captures and d6 Queen
captures and d6 is also an option Queen
captures on d6 seems to be the most
natural move after a white develops f5
is coming and the black will get a very
nice position and a very nice expansion
at the Kings side but here if Abby
doesn't play Queen captures on d6 nor
does he play Knight captures on d6
rather he plays a seek after Sun b6 and
it was a very interesting grandmaster
johanna budwiq hammer said that this
means that Fabi is playing for the win
and I saw an interview with Fabi after
this game he said that he did have
disposition analyzed that on the table
at home and he said that he knew that
this wasn't really all that great but
white had to play like like a perfect
game to punish this this move and Fabi
said that he thought that the best
continuation here is definitely Queen to
b3 but Anand decides to go tonight f2 d2
he attacks the knight on e4 and now we
have f5 so okay
Fabi did the double his D pawn but he
does have a very strong night in the
center of the board nice to a3 we have
Bishop to e6 nice to see 2 now and
Knight captures and e2 Queen captures
and now ff4 not allowing this night to
gain any activity via night 3 3 we have
rook a to e1 Queen comes to f6f-3 and
now rook to f7 Fabi is preparing to
double Roxanne DF file rock to e2 rook a
to f8 we have night 2 e1 and now Knight
to e7 and now what do you do here well
your knight anyone isn't really the best
piece you do want to activate it somehow
you have to you know Riemann over your
pieces and get the night maybe to d3 and
from there it will maybe be able to
become a bit more active so Bishop to c2
we have a 5 Bishop to b3 now
and rock 2g8 and getting the rook out of
this bishops diagonal and also the king
will have to move as well
Queen to d3 we have Bishop to d7 now
comes a for not allowing b5 King moves
to h8 now both the king and rook have
moved from the special diagonal Queen to
d2
we have h5 and now Knight does come to
d3 and here it seems like you would like
to push up on here but that would be too
hasty if you did something like this
then captures captures and after rook
captures there really isn't and anything
for black here I mean it would be a
winning position for white so not a
hasty move like this but instead Fabi
finds a different idea a very active one
he plays Knight to f5 now going for that
very strong e3 squared the the pawn on
f4 is guarding it very nicely and the
bishop captures on d5 is the best way to
go if you allow night to e3 without
getting any compensation than Knight
from e3 will I even be guarding the pawn
on d5 so we have Bishop captures 93 now
of course your rook is attacked on f1
but also the bishop on d5 is undefended
so there is only one move here for white
and that is a rook captures we have F
captures and queen characters on e3 so
Fabi is now up in the exchange he has a
rook for a night but he still has to
activate those works to be to be able to
do something and Anand has two extra
points for being down the exchange
so first the Bishop captures an a4 there
is time to grab a pawn rook to a 1 we
have rook to e7 attacking the Queen
Queen to d2 and now Bishop to b5 rook
captures on a5 on and grabs upon as well
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
rook to e1 check King to f2 and now rook
F to e8 and here the position is very
very difficult for white White has to
figure out how to approach this Fabi
said that when he played this move he
thought that he was winning and he
couldn't really find any good moves for
white I thought that if G 3 then Queen
to a5 is coming you know FG 3 then Queen
2
five wood ideas of queen coming to h3
and of course if you capture the Queen
then rook eight to eat who will be
checkmate
so as Fabi said in an interview and did
dodged a bullet here but Allen finds
rock trade it's the strongest move
recommended by the engine and it keeps
white alive so Queen to f4
we have rook captures rook captures and
now Queen to d1 a move like g3 does seem
to solve all the whites problems but
after Queen to see one white really
doesn't doesn't have a good move here
your B to pawn is attacked and you know
a queen to e1 is coming and you're gonna
lose something if you protect the pond
and Queen e1 check is coming King moves
and now rook comes with check King h3
Queen F 1 this will be checkmate now the
rock is blocking Queens defense of f1 so
after rook captures on e8 I'm gonna try
screen to d1 he gives up the h2 point we
have Queen captures and now Queen back
to d2 so a very interesting defense
Queen to h4 check King to f12 into h1
check King to f2 and Fabri repeats Queen
12 h4 check King f1 and this is move 42
now the time control has been reached
and here Fabi does not repeat and he
doesn't want to draw here he plays rook
to e8 the rock is now ready to come to a
2
it's a very dangerous position of course
in grabbing a pawn here there's a really
no time for this if you grab it then
rock j1 and white well white is lost
here you move the king the queen is
coming here
and there's really no good move you can
make it you can't escape with the King
the rook will simply win the Queen
whatever you do there's there's really
no point in in in doing something like
this so after rook to a mmm after rook
to 8 we have a king to eat to now rook
to a-1 pink the d3 trying to escape and
b5 now not allowing the King to escape
the c4 here on in place c4 we have pawn
captures King captures and now comes
Queen to f4
offering the trade of Queens and it's
very interesting
should Anand accept the trade of Queens
here and try to hold this position being
up upon well not really and after some
consideration
decides against this if you play this
and now for example put B for King g7 is
coming b5 and the problem is I've
product to be one there is no way for
white to ever push b6 and there are
really no useful moves here for white
black well black will eventually win win
all all of the points and win the game
for example if you if white tries to
activate his skin for example King the
five black will defend his pawn on d6
and then after white figures out any
kind of plan attacking the g2 pawn king
captures rook captures b6 is coming now
but now the King will also prevent the
pawn so after Bishop to d5 going for
Bishop to e6 to prevent pawn from being
pushed all the way to H 1 H 4 now comes
the best resets blocking but now rook to
D to d5 protecting the pawn and now
route d3 simply wasting a move because
white it doesn't have useful moves here
King attacks rook now simply rugby 3 and
there is no there is no way to defend
this now you will finally lose this pawn
and then black will activate his King
and you know push would push the White
King back and win the game so of course
that's only one of the ways you can do
this but Allen decides against it so
Queen to e2 avoiding a trade of Queens
we need to see one this comes with check
and now what do you do here if you play
Queen to be king b3 then you get Queen
to d1 and after Queen's are exchanged
that's that's a winning end game for
Fabi on the other hand after Queen c1
check if you go King to be a king to d3
again Queen d1 check exchanges Queens
and it will be a winning end game for
Fabi
so after Queen C one of tries King to be
5 and this is a very important moment in
the game because here you could try you
could try a lot of ideas but there is
only only one move here that will that
will win the game for Fabi and that move
is Quinta c8 and it's it's the move Fabi
did play in in the game if you try now
to force things with Queen to e1 then
after King Queen captures the rook
captures and before
black will not be able to win the same
game because the white bone is already
on before and after King gay sex the
pond will be able to be pushed forward
so I probably your engine my engine as
well it doesn't give all that much here
for black but I saw this position was
evaluated by the Norwegian super
computer and it gives a queen to see it
as the only winning move and completely
crushing and Fabi plays it the idea
became behind Quinta CA tis Queen to a6
check of course now winning winning the
Queen un'ytu and there is no good
defense against this if you try King
before then you get Queen b8 check Queen
blocks now Queen captures captures and
now rook to d1 and it's a different
position than the one we had if you
remember the this one because here the
point is already on before there is no
threat here for black white will simply
continue playing on the other hand here
there's no time to push before rookies
already attacking the d4 pawn and after
King C foreign King g7 very two
important temples were one and the black
will indeed win this game so after Queen
to c8 the only other idea other than
moving the King is maybe you can try to
move the Queen if you try and move the
Queen then you get Queen Queen a6 chip
King moves Queen checks again King moves
and now after rook check you will simply
force the King and then black will win
the Queen and the game of course
so after this Queen to see it move King
to be success played and here Fabi said
that he knew that this was winning you
know in a whole lot of different ways
Queen to be it was played now it comes
King to c6 and after rook to c1
it was in this position and move 50 that
Vishwanathan Anand resigned the game why
did he resign well if you go King D 7
you try to escape then comes Roxy 7 King
captures Queen b6 check King moves and
now rook e8 well we need a winner the
Queen King King has the move and and
rook captures honey 2 wins the game and
the Queen it wins the Queen and the game
on the other hand after this rook to c1
check if you try to block Bishop to c4
then okay it seems like maybe you will
be able to defend but it loses to this
variation Quincy eight check King moves
and now rook captures on c4 it seems
like white white will now be up upon but
after Queen to g8 check this is the move
you had to find you realize that there
is no square where the king can go to
and still protect the White Queen
so here the king has the part where this
Queen King captures and now Queen
captures on c4 it's all over black wins
this game so after rook c1 Ireland
resigned and a very nice victory for
Fabiano Caruana so we should never
forget to show the correct standings
after the game so let's do it now
so we don't forget so let's check it out
after round eight we have a four player
tie so it's Magnus Carlsen with four
points then Wesley so also with four
points and then he Cara Nakamura with
four and Fabiana Caruana all with four
points then mamedyarov
iranian anand kurakin Osceola Grove and
Dingley one who left the tournament of
course there's no real point in counting
him so yeah four player tie before the
final round and I believe the Fabiano
karana is the only player that has the
white pieces tomorrow or should I say
today because I'm making the video today
but yeah
in the final round five is the only one
that has the white pieces and he I just
wanted to mention if you can see here a
shock remedy are of three and a half out
of eight so he will not be playing in
the final round he already played all of
his rounds a seeded face being leerin
but as you can see he did not win a
single game in this tournament and I saw
an interview with him and he said that
well it's it was very hard for him to
remember when was the last time he
played a tournament without actually
winning any games I believe he mentioned
there was some 10 years ago or either
ten years ago or in 2010 so either ten
or eight years ago and you know he will
sometimes lose games in the tournament
but he will always win games but he says
that he feels you know he's not too
happy about not winning even one game
but he did have a huge tooth ache for
the first couple of rounds and I believe
he had to go
have a tooth operation or it was some
kind of an emergency so yeah I can
imagine that playing such strong players
would it to take is never pleasant but
yeah we have one more round to go I do
hope you are enjoying the coverage so
far and that you have enjoyed this game
I would like to thank max baggett Danny
McCullough John French and John trench
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon with a nice video or
two from the final round of the 2018 all
t-box norway championship thank you all
and good luck in the photo challenge